in many cases the behaviors that are
motivating to us that are attractive to
us are dependent on the people that we
are around um so one way to think about
this is that we are all members of
tribes uh some of the tribes are big
some of them are small like big ones
might be what it means to be american or
what it means to be french or something
like that and small ones could be you
know what it means to be a neighbor on
your street or a member of your local
crossfit gym or a volunteer at your
local high school or whatever but all of
these tribes large and small have a set
of shared expectations that for what it
means to be part of the group
and when you belong to that tribe when
you have friends there when you feel
like you want to fit in with that group
habits that align with the shared
expectations of the tribe are very
attractive and you want to do them and
habits that go against the grain of the
shared expectations are very
unattractive and so
one of the ways to make habits more
attractive is to join a group where your
desired behavior is the normal behavior